o
[Música]
Olá pessoal é uma satisfação estar aqui
com vocês compartilhar um pouquinho da
minha experiência de vida profissional
desses últimos 32 anos de trabalho eu
sou Elisa eu ia formação acadêmica na
área de biologia mas sempre me atraiu
muito área da gestão trabalha gente a
empresa trabalha em Governo do Estado e
hoje eu estou trabalhando em uma ONG
aqui em Mato Grosso do Sul eu cheguei
Mato Grosso do Sul há 33 anos e o
Pantanal sempre me atraiu muito você
sabe que o Pantanal é uma maior área
alagada do mundo mais de 210 mil km
quadrados deixe sessenta e cinco
porcento está em Mato Grosso do Sul e
não sei os mais humilde ver o franjão
uma beleza o beleza em todos os sentidos
em termos de
espécies em termos de cores em termos de
paisagens do Pantanal realmente é uma
beleza e nessas belezas todas eu
encontrei a 33 32 anos mais ou menos uma
pessoa muito especial aqui Mato Grosso
do Sul que a doutora Neiva Guedes ela
viu uma arara-azul arara-azul eu acho
que vocês todos já tiveram a
oportunidade de conhecer uma espécie
linda maravilhosa e eu que estava
ameaçada de extinção e começou a
trabalhar agora Azul uma paixão
inconfundível é impressionante ver nem
vaghetti ao longo desses anos
trabalhando com muito empenho e
dedicação para salvar esta espécie
é mas a minha área veio a contribuir um
pouco diferente do que da pesquisa e da
conservação entanto a paixão de seus
miolos à frente do trabalho de
conservação
foi possível constatar a necessidade
para que os projetos continuasse de que
houvesse a sustentabilidade financeira
aliada essa conservação ambiental essa
apresentação diferentes espécies e o
projeto Arara azul é um caso a ser
exposto e que serve até como poder ele
tem um reconhecimento em termos de
pesquisa e dedicação em biologia
resultados um reconhecimento no mundo
inteiro que hoje a professora Neiva
Guedes adquiriu ao longo desses anos
todos mas a área que gostaria de expor
para vocês hoje o tema que ela quebrado
é como a gente consegue conciliar
trabalha em uma ONG porque não tem
recursos
oriundos do caso de governo estado
é
exclusivamente que depende de empresa
City pessoas da sua sustentabilidade
financeira que você pensando um pouco
nesses projetos a gente pode perceber
que a sua paixão de um biólogo da sua
equipe pela conservação por uma espécie
não é o suficiente para que ele consiga
manter a sua pesquisa nem precisa de
recurso que nasceram sustentabilidade
Econômica é fundamental nos projetos de
pesquisa Ainda mais quando não tem um
atendedor quando não tem recursos
governamentais que é um caso do projeto
arara azul então é necessário que várias
frentes sejam compostas para que a
manutenção do projeto exista já são 31
anos de projeto de dedicação e de
continuidade de sementes resultados E
para isso daqui isso fosse possível nós
anos dedicamos a frentes de onde esse
serviço ambiental pudesse ser
transformado em produtos e serviços a
diferentes públicos e uma delas e
gostaria de compartilhar com vocês foram
campanhas para poder apoiar esse projeto
uma delas é a campanha do time é campeão
da Oceania É bem interessante são minhas
Santo naturais com artificiais lá no
Pantanal ninhos de arara azul arara azul
mas Pet linda maravilhosa estava
altamente ameaçada de extinção porque
ela é muito suscetível a
extinção é muito vulnerável ela é muito
especializada naquela comissão dois
coquinhos apenas Bocaiuva épure faço
assim meus basicamente duas espécies de
árvores que ela mandou vir a Xingu uva
por causa do sério que é mais macio mais
quando o projeto começou essas árvores
estavam diminuindo em número por causa
do desmatamento na espécie por causa do
tráfico sendo levada e depois da sua
beleza
o símbolo do Pantanal é uma raça linda
maravilhosa aí projeto começou e com
isso né várias dificuldades foram
encontradas EA necessidade da
sustentabilidade financeira foram
buscando apoio dos envelopes com o apoio
porque as distâncias são muito longe de
montadoras para poder ter um veículo até
que conseguisse Neve com o apoio de uma
depois de muitos nãos conseguisse então
apoio Então passou a ser um dos
patrocinadores da do projeto é essa
montadora e quais são as necessidades
existem muito são pesquisadores que
precisam ter a sua manutenção né
física que não será para sua
sobrevivência tanto familiar que nos
projetos
são insumos são entre as culturas são
distâncias veículo enfim os valores são
altos e um projeto que fica
continuamente numa área com muitas
distâncias com muitas dificuldades e de
logística e principalmente
ultimamente com as mudanças climáticas
você só imagino tudo que a gente tem
enfrentado com as mudanças climáticas em
virtude das chuvas fortes e isolados
alagando os ninhos
a embaixo e Unidade da espécie por falta
de alimentação e os incêndios que já vem
há três anos aí mas sacando no Pantanal
tanto no norte como aqui no sul né que
fosse ele se por cento aqui Mato Grosso
do Sul massacrando a espécie outras
espécies também que existem nesse bioma
Mas falando da arara azura tanto de
continuidade desse símbolo que a gente
utiliza inclusive para sensibilizar para
conscientizar as pessoas da importância
da Conservação da biodiversidade
criou-se então alguns produtos que são
pra diferentes públicos com a campanha
adote um livro estava comentando ela é
tanto pezinhos naturais como eu comentei
essas duas espécies de árvores como os
artificiais que a professora dele e
produziu daquele se fosse Siri tinta
Então ela disse quando precisou as
cavidades foram ao longo dos anos
adequadas para que houvesse a reprodução
e até que tivesse sucesso nesse sim
então nós temos hoje muitos aturar essa
mensagem oficiais então esses ninhos são
objecto de uma campanha que se chama
toque mim onde as pessoas podem adotar
meios naturais artificiais e receber
todas as informações técnicas que
acontecem o Sininho podendo inclusive
batizar o filhote fica ali nascer às
vezes não não é uma azul e outra espécie
que o corpo mim batizado com o nome aqui
escolher Nós também temos outras
campanhas É voltado inclusive aqui na
cidade Campo Grande que hoje nós temos
um projeto bem interessante para outra
espécie de arara que a Canindé
amarela com azul diferente um pouco da
Azul eu quê que foi o início de todo o
projeto mas expertise veio com esse
primeiro projeto aqui para Campo Grande
e tão os filhotes e com isso contribuir
de forma adoção simbólica é claro né
muita gente liga aqui pergunta mas como
eu posso levar Não não pode levar o
filhote para casa não filhote fica
aquilo adoção simbólica contribui
financeiramente com o projeto e recebe
todas as informações
certificaram desse filhotinho que nasceu
mas também temos o turismo de observação
que hoje as pessoas os grupos podem vir
acompanhar os nossos projetos e também e
colaborarem com uma doação para que haja
continuidade da pesquisa e da
conservação então a diferença do turista
porque nós utilizamos muito turismo com
uma ferramenta educativa então tu está
bem acompanha são os projetos eles sabem
tudo conhecimento técnico candidata
transformado numa linguagem Bem Simples
então eles saiba que tá acontecendo a
importância de conservar e depois leva
para sua origem para sua cidade seu país
enfim o que ele o filme a importância de
proteger o espécie por exemplo com
Maracatu ou uma outra espécie que é
estudada por um ecossistema como um todo
e com isso também a gente então recebe
doações desses turistas que contribuem
para a manutenção nos projetos de
pesquisa e Conservação
temos uma política também bem definida
para pessoa jurídica para empresas que
queiram mostrar a sua responsabilidade
socioambiental seu público e também
pessoa física que tira contribuir de
várias formas de forma voluntária de
forma o recurso financeiro com um objeto
recebemos até câmeras fotográficas enfim
várias formas existem para ajudar o
projeto de conservação e isso passa a
ser um desafio
Então porque eu trago aqui para vocês
hoje que é possível sim que conciliar A
Conservação ambiental a pesquisa
manutenção com o sustentabilidade
financeira através
os dentes de ideias de produtos de
campanhas de prestamos serviços como
palestras concursos como nós temos aqui
nós temos um centro de sentabilidade em
Campo Grande com a nossa sete Nós também
oferecemos cursos para diferentes
públicos inclusive oficinas de educação
ambiental para crianças professores e
com isso então nós vamos arrecadando
recursos financeiros para manutenção dos
projetos então não necessariamente
precisamos depender de governo as duas
civil do Estado A não ser que queiram
ouvir tava com isso mas também nossa
trabalhamos em parceria isso é muito
importante mas não necessariamente com o
recurso financeiro Mas seria por exemplo
de políticas públicas é muito importante
você geral conhecimento de seu projeto e
você levar esse conhecimento das
diferentes esferas públicas esse
conhecimento vai fazer então que os
gestores né bem sim de é
aquele conhecimento gerar A Conservação
outro objetivo que se queira em prol da
conservação nessa que diversidade da
melhoria da nossa qualidade de vida
então isso influenciar políticas
públicas é uma parceria mas não precisa
ser necessariamente financeira Mas isso
é uma opção de cada um as ONGs hoje as
cumpre um papel fundamental na nossa
sociedade é